GOOD TO SEE YOU.
BUCKLE UP FOR TONIGHT'S
"HANNITY" AND BRACE FOR IMPACT.
TOMORROW MORNING THE MUELLER
REPORT WILL BE RELEASED AND THE
MADNESS BEGINS.
OUR SOURCES TELLING US MINIMAL
REDACTION.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL SEE
THIS AND STILL THE MEDIA MOB OF
DEMOCRATS, TRUMP HATERS WILL GET
THERE ONE LAST CHANCE TO
BREATHLESSLY COME HYSTERICALLY
HYPERVENTILATE OVER NOTHING.
IT PAYS LESS VENGEFUL HOAX, A
RUSSIAN COLLUSION WHICH TAUGHT
THAT HAS COME UP TOTALLY AND
COMPLETELY AND UTTERLY EMPTY.
NO COLLUSION, NO CONSPIRACY, NO
OBSTRUCTION.
NO MATTER WHAT SENTENCES,
PARAGRAPHS, PAGES, DEMOCRATS,
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA FIXATE ON,
NONE OF IT CHANGES THE OUTCOME.
WE ALREADY KNOW THE OUTCOME.
IF YOU CAN GO TO VEGAS YOU CAN
BET ON WHAT I'M TELLING YOU.
FOUR SEPARATE MEDICATIONS HAVE
CLEARED DONALD TRUMP IS A TRUMP
CAMPAIGN
INCLUDING THE ALSO POWERFUL
SPECIAL COUNSEL FILLED WITH
INVESTIGATORS FOR ALMOST ALL OF
THEM, BIG TIME DEMOCRATIC DONORS
AND SUPPORTERS OF HILLARY.
EVEN SOMEONE WHO WENT TO HER
VICTORY PARTY.
AFTER 22 MONTHS, 2800 SUBPOENAS,
500 SEARCH WARRANTS, INTERVIEWS
WITH 500 PEOPLE, THE MUELLER
REPORT CONCLUDED "THE
INVESTIGATION DID NOT ESTABLISH
THAT MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN CONSPIRED COORDINATED
WITH THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT AND
ITS ELECTION INTERFERENCE
ACTIVITIES."
DEVIN NUNES WARNED US ABOUT AND
THE THOUSAND 14.
NO ONE INSIDE THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
CONSPIRED OR COORDINATED WITH
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
NO ONE AND THAT IS NOW A FACT.
TWO YEARS AND YOU'VE HAD YOUR
TINFOIL HAT CONSPIRACY THEORIES
YOUR DAILY LIVES AND THE MEDIA
MOB, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WORKING IN UNISON.
TRYING TO SLANDER, SMEAR AND
DESTROY A DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT
AND EVERYBODY AROUND HIM.
THEY HAVE FOR TWO YEARS FLAT OUT
LIED TO YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
WE HAVE THE PROOF.
LET'S TAKE A LITTLE TRIP DOWN
MEMORY WITCH HUNT LANE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ARE ABOUT TO FIND OUT AT
THE NEW PRESIDENT OF OUR COUNTRY
WILL DO WHAT RUSSIA WANTS.
>> IF THERE ARE NO SHE WAS ON
THE TRUMP HUMAN CENTIPEDE THAT
ARE NOT ABOUT TO RUSH RUSSIA.
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
>> THIS CLOUD WILL HANG OVER HIM
AND MINA WHERE HE STANDS.
>> HE MAY BE THE FIRST PRESIDENT
TO FACE THE REAL PROSPECT OF
JAIL TIME.
>> IT IS CLEAR THAT HE IS NOW
CONNECTED THE DOTS BETWEEN A
MASSIVE OBSTRUCTION INTENDED TO
HIDE THE TRUTH.
>> THIS PRESIDENT NEEDS TO BE
IMPEACHED AND I BELIEVE THAT AND
I BELIEVE THERE WAS COLLUSION.
DONALD TRUMP IS DONE, HE HAS
DONE.
THERE IS NO QUESTION.
>> HE HAS TO KNOW HIS FUTURE
LOOKS LIKE IT IS BEHIND BARS.
>> WE HAVE A TREASONOUS
PRESIDENT AND WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DEAL WITH THE
PRESIDENT WHO WITTINGLY OR
UNWILLINGLY HAS BEEN COMPROMISE
COMPROMISED.
>> THIS IS NOT FUNNY.
THIS IS REALLY BAD.
FOR THE RECORD, WE ARE ALL
REALLY NERVOUS.
>> THE BEGINNING OF THE END OF
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
>> YOU COULD FEEL THE THREAD
BEING PULLED, I BELIEVE THIS IS
THE BEGINNING OF THE END.
>> THE WALLS ARE CLOSING IN.
>> HE IS DESPERATE.
HE IS OBVIOUSLY FLAILING AROUND
BECAUSE HE FEELS THE WALLS
CLOSING IN.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE
EVERYTHING HE CAN AND TRASH IN A
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> MR. TRUMP IS SEEING MORE AND
MORE OF THE WALLS CLOSING IN ON
HIM WHICH IS WHY HE IS BECOMING
INCREASINGLY DESPERATE.
>> WHAT IF HE REFUSES TO OPEN
THE WHITE HOUSE STORY.
WHAT IF HE FIRES AND A
SECRET SERVICE AGENT WHO WOULD
ALLOW THE FEDERAL MARSHAL?
WHAT IF HE DECIDES I DON'T HAVE
TO FOLLOW THE LAW?
I REFUSE TO BE HELD UNDER THE
LAW, NO MARSHAL CAN GET INTO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> THE PRESIDENCY IS EFFECTIVELY
A RUSSIAN OP.
PARTISAN WARFARE BETWEEN
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS INTERNATIONAL WARFARE
AGAINST OUR COUNTRY.
>> Sean: THEY WERE ALL
PSYCHOTIC AND THEY HAVE ALL LOST
IT.
CAN ANYONE EVER REALLY BELIEVE
THE COLLUSION TRUTH RACHEL
MADDOW EVER AGAIN?
SHE AND ALL THESE OTHERS CALMING
THEIR VIEWERS AND BY THE WAY,
MANY FOR A LOT OF FINANCIAL
GAIN.
TOMORROW THEY WILL GIVE IT THERE
ONE LAST COLLEGE TRY, GOOD LUCK
AND YOU CAN EXPECT MORE OF WHAT
YOU JUST SAW ON STEROIDS HUMAN
GROWTH HORMONES.
IT IS OFFICIALLY THE MEDIA MOB,
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S LAST
CHANCE TO REVIVE THEIR FAVORITE,
PSYCHOTIC CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
THEY STILL DON'T KNOW IT'S DONE.
IT IS OVER.
THEY LOST AGAIN.
IT IS ELECTION NIGHT ALL OVER
AGAIN AND 2016 AND HERE'S THE
SAD REALITY, THEY WILL NEVER
APOLOGIZE.
THEY WANT RETRACT FALSE REPORTS
FOR THEIR POLITICALLY MOTIVATED
DAILY HYSTERIA.
THERE BREATHLESS, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, COLLUSION INSANITY!
NEVER ARE.
THEY WILL NEVER OWN UP TO BEING
A PART OF THE BIGGEST MOST
DANGEROUS FRAUD CONSPIRACY
THEORY EVER PERPETRATED AGAINST
WE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHEN THEY FINALLY REALIZED THEY
LOST AND THEY DID AND THEY LIED
AND THEY DID AND I FAILED ON A
SPECTACULAR LEVEL AND THEY DID,
THEY WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
SLIDE IN THE NEXT CONSPIRACY
THEORY.
THEY WILL ACT AS IF THIS NEVER
HAPPENED BADGERING, HOPE YOU
FORGOT.
AS I SAID MAINSTREAM MEDIA,
SO-CALLED JOURNALISM IS DEAD IN
AMERICA.
THE FOOLS WHO CLAIM TO HAVE A
MONOPOLY OF FACTS, THEY DON'T
WANT TO REPORT HIS KEY FINDINGS.
LET ME GO BACK FROM THE MUELLER
REPORT.
THE INVESTIGATION DID NOT
ESTABLISH THAT MEMBERS OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN CONSPIRED OR
CORRELATED WITH THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT AND ITS ELECTION
INTERFERENCE ACTIVITY.
MUELLER WORDS, NOT HANNITY.
A DIRECT QUOTE.
AN UNDENIABLE, IRREFUTABLE FACT.
THIS IS THE PARAGRAPH THAT THE
LIARS ON THE LEFT CAN BARELY
BRING THEMSELVES TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
WITH THE FAKE COLLUSION
NARRATIVE, YOU CAN SEE THE MOB
SWITCHING THEIR NARRATIVE.
MAYBE WE WILL GET HIM ON
OBSTRUCTION.
WE NEED HIS TAX RETURNS.
WE WILL HAVE A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING AND WE WILL AGREE
TO GO AFTER HIM ON THIS.
GET THIS, OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
FROM A CRIME THAT WAS NEVER
COMMITTED.
HOW CAN YOU OBSTRUCT WITHOUT THE
UNDERLYING CRIME?
BY THE WAY, WITH THE STATUTE OF
OBSTRUCTION YOU NEED INTENT.
THAT IS REQUIRED BY LAW WHEN ONE
HAS CONSISTENTLY AND REPEATEDLY
AND LOUDLY BUT THE PRESIDENT
RIGHTLY PROCLAIMING HIS
INNOCENCE.
HE ACTED THE WAY INNOCENT PEOPLE
ACT, THEY ARE OUTRAGED.
THE PRESIDENT WAS NEVER CHARGED
WITH OBSTRUCTION, NOT BY MUELLER
OR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
AND NOT EVEN UNCLE ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
TOMORROW AND THE REPORT YOU
MIGHT SEE INFORMATION ABOUT,
WHILE THE PRESIDENT FIRED JIM
COMEY.
THAT IS NOT OBSTRUCTION.
EVEN HE POINTED OUT TO THE
PRESIDENT CAN FIRE AN FBI
DIRECTOR FOR ANY REASON OR NO
REASON AT ALL AND YOU MIGHT
HEAR --
IF THEY WILL HANG ON TO EVIDENCE
ABOUT WHAT THE PRESIDENT TALKED
ABOUT FIRING ROD ROSENSTEIN.
OTHER OFFICIALS LIKE HE TALKED
ABOUT FIRING MUELLER HIMSELF OR
THE PRESIDENT WISHED A
33-YEAR-OLD VETERAN, A HERO WHO
SERVED THIS COUNTRY INCUMBENT,
GENERAL FLYNN WOULD NOT GET IN
TROUBLE.
HE TALKED ABOUT, THIS IS
RIDICULOUS.
GUESS WHAT?
THE PRESIDENT NEVER FIRED ROD
ROSENSTEIN OR MUELLER OR JEFF
SESSIONS OR ANY OF THE DEMOCRATS
HIRED TO SUSTAIN THE WITCH HUNT.
HE NEVER STOPPED THE
INVESTIGATION OR IMPEDED OR
OBSTRUCTION.
HE DIDN'T IMPEDE AGAINST THE
CASE AGAINST GENERAL FLYNN OR
ANY OTHER TARGET OF THIS
WITCH HUNT.
JUTTING FROM A ROOFTOP THAT
YOU'RE INNOCENT AS THE PRESIDENT
HAS, A VICTIM OF A WITCH HUNT,
THAT IS NOT A CRIME.
EXPRESSING FRUSTRATION ABOUT
INJUSTICE IS NOT OBSTRUCTION.
TALKING IS NOT OBSTRUCTION.
THINKING ABOUT SOMETHING IS NOT
OBSTRUCTION.
KIND OF LIKE, LIKE ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
ANOTHER DEEP STATE RAT TALKING
ABOUT WEARING A WIRE BECAUSE
THEY WANTED TO SPY ON THE
PRESIDENT.
CONSPIRING AND TALKING ABOUT
USING THE 25TH AMENDMENT TO
REMOVE THE PRESIDENT FROM OFFIC
OFFICE.
THERE ARE OFFICIALS RIGHT NOW IN
OUR DOJ RIGHT NOW THAT ACTUALLY
HAD THOSE REAL CONVERSATIONS BUT
NONE OF THEM ARE BEING CHARGED
WITH THE CRIME BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T ACT.
HE DIDN'T COMMIT.
ONE IN THIS CASE, MAYBE THE
OTHER IS DEAD WHICH WE WILL GET
TO.
IN THIS CASE THEY DIDN'T WEAR
THE WIRE AND THEY DIDN'T USE
THE 25TH AMENDMENT.
HE NEVER ACTED AND I TALKED
ABOUT IT, TALKING IS NOT A CRIM
CRIME.
THE HEAT MEDIUM MOM AND IF THEY
REALLY CARED ABOUT OBSTRUCTION
AND WHEN YOU HEAR THESE PEOPLE
TOMORROW, OKAY, HAVE A
GREAT CASE FOR THEM.
WHY OH WHY DID THEY IGNORE THE
BLATANT OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
COMMITTED BY ONE OF THEIR OWN,
THEIR FAVORITE CANDIDATE,
HILLARY CLINTON.
WE KNOW SHE VIOLATED THE
ESPIONAGE ACT, IT IS A FACT.
SHE STOLE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
ON AN UNSECURED SERVER.
HERE IS THE LAW.
IRREFUTABLE AND YOU CAN SEE IT
RIGHT THERE, AND CONTROVERTED
AND OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE, EVEN
COMEY ADMITTED SHE DID THIS.
SHE DELETED 33,000 SUBPOENAED
EMAILS, WASHED THE HARD DRIVE
WITH BLEACH AND REMOVE THE
SIM CARDS AND HAD THEM DESTROYED
WITH HAMMERS IN CASE THOSE
EMAILS WERE STILL ON THERE.
THE MEDIA MOB THAT WILL BE SO
OUTRAGED OVER OBSTRUCTION
TOMORROW, THIS WAS THE BIGGEST
SLAM DUNK OBSTRUCTION CASE EVER.
IT HAD AN UNDERLYING CRIME AND
INTENT, THE INTENT IN THIS CASE
DESTROY THE EVIDENCE OF THE
CRIME.
OR MEDIA, MORE LIBERAL
SELECTIVE, PHONY MORAL OUTRAGE.
THAT IS WHAT YOU WILL SEE
TOMORROW.
MEMBER IN THE BRETT KAVANAUGH
CASE, I BELIEVE, I BELIEVE.
WHERE ARE THEY NOW?
WE HAVE SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS OF
RATE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT RIGHT
NOW AGAINST THE
DEMOCRATIC LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
THEY'RE ALL QUIET.
HE SAT WITH THE COVINGTON
HIGH SCHOOL KIDS.
WE SEE IT WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
AND WE
SEE IT WITH THEIR NEW GREEN DEAL
AND SOCIALIST POLICIES.
BY THE WAY, HILLARY WAS NEVER
CHARGED WITH HER CRIME BECAUSE
HER INVESTIGATION WHICH WE NOW
KNOW WAS BY THE DEEP STATE.
THAT IS WHY LINDSEY GRAHAM THE
SENATOR FROM SOUTH CAROLINA IS
NOT RIGHTLY INVESTIGATING THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE CLINTON
EMAIL SCANDAL.
IN THIS CASE THE EVIDENCE IS
OVERWHELMING AND
INCONTROVERTIBLE.
IT IS NOW CRYSTAL CLEAR WE ON
THE SHOW AND WE HAVE THIS
ENSEMBLE CAST, RADIO AND TV, THE
PEOPLE YOU SEE ALL FOR THE LAST
TWO YEARS BEEN RIGHT ALL ALONG.
THE CLINTON INVESTIGATION WAS
FIXED IN HER FAVOR BY A FEW
HIGH-RANKING BUREAUCRATS WANTED
HER TO BE PRESIDENT.
THEY WANT TO TRUMP TO LOSE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP FACED A MODERN
DAY PERSECUTION AT THE HANDS OF
THOSE VERY SAME PEOPLE, THE SAME
PEOPLE THAT GAVE HER A PASS RATE
FOR INVESTIGATION.
IF THE DEEP STATE WAS REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT COLLUSION AND
WHY IS THERE NO INVESTIGATION
INTO COLLUSION?
WE NOW KNOW UKRAINE IS BEGGING
TO GIVE THEM EVIDENCE.
THEY ARE ADMITTING THEY COLLUDED
TO HELP HILLARY IN THE 2016
ELECTION THANKS TO JOHN SOLOMON.
WE ALSO KNOW THE UKRAINIAN
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL DEAD THIS
AND IS ADMITTING THIS
THIS ROBERT MUELLER GOING TO BE
REAPPOINTED TO INVESTIGATE THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND ALL OF ITS
REPUBLICAN DONORS?
WHAT ABOUT THE DOSSIER?
HE HAD THE DOSSIER WITH OF ALL
THINGS IMAGINE THIS, RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT LIES.
MISINFORMATION, PROPAGANDA NOW
DEBUNKED.
TONIGHT ACCORDING TO POLITICAL
WE ARE LEARNING THAT THE DOJ
INSPECTORS REPORT WILL LIKELY
TARGET THE AUTHOR OF THE DOSSIER
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
THAT IS FINE BUT THE REAL FOCUS
SHOULD BE ON THE PERSON THAT
PAID FOR THAT LINE DOSSIER.
THOSE THAT NEVER VERIFIED THAT
DOSSIER AND COMMITTED A FRAUD ON
THE PFIZER TOM MACK FISA PORT.
THOSE
THAT LEAVE THAT TO THEIR FRIENDS
IN THE MEDIA TO INFLUENCE THE
ELECTION.
THOSE THAT USE IT TO DENY AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN, CARTER PAGE OF
HIS CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AND
USE THOSE RUSSIAN LIES TO COMMIT
A FRAUD AGAIN AND AGAIN, FOUR
SEPARATE TIMES ON THE FISA QUOT
QUOTE.
THANKFULLY OUR CALLS FOR TRUTH
AND JUSTICE ARE ALL ABOUT TO BE
ANSWERED.
AFTER MADNESS, HYSTERIA AND
BREATHLESS REPORTING TOMORROW
BEGINS TO DIE DOWN AND IT WILL,
THIS IS WHAT IS COMING NEXT IN
THE MONTHS AND WEEKS.
THERE IS A COMPLETE AVALANCHE OF
TRUTH THAT WILL START TO CASCADE
DOWN ON ALL OF THE DEEP STATE
BAD ACTORS, THE CORRUPT MEDIA,
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
ALL THE PEOPLE MISSING IN ACTION
AND WHAT IS THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT CRIMINAL
REFERRALS COMING FROM
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES.
MORE WE EXPECT FROM THE REPORT,
HIS REPORT ON THE FISA
INVESTIGATION.
COMMITTING FRAUD TO FISA JUDGES.
THEY KNOWINGLY LIE TO THOSE
JUDGES AND MELTS NOT FORGET THE
INVESTIGATION LEAKING.
CONVERSATIONS, CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, THE APPLICATIONS, THE
FISA APPLICATIONS THEMSELVES.
ESPECIALLY THE LAST ONE, PAGES
TEN THROUGH 12.
WE LOOK AT THE GANG OF EIGHT
INFORMATION.
WHICH OF THE FBI KNOW AND WHEN
DID THEY KNOW WHERE TO?
INFORMATION OF CHRISTOPHER
STEELE.
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT, THE
INVESTIGATION INTO SPYING.
THEY SPIED ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AND IT HAPPENED.
THESE INVESTIGATIONS WILL BRING
A LOT OF BAD ACTORS TO JUSTICE
AND THE THE CONSEQUENCES WILL BE
STEEP AND TODAY WE HAVE BEEN
RIGHT ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT HAS
TRANSPIRED SURROUNDING THE DEEP
STATES ABUSE OF POWER, THE
WITCH HUNT OF TWO PRESIDENT.
TOMORROW YOU WILL SEE THE LAST
MASS HYSTERIA ON THIS TOPIC.
THIS WEEK I NEARLY HAD A HEART
ATTACK.
WHY?
"THE WASHINGTON POST" THEY MAKE
IT A PULITZER PRIZE FOR THEIR
HOAX COVERAGE.
THE COURAGE TO ADMIT ANY
ARTICLE, LOOK AT THIS.
FOX NEWS HAS BEEN RIGHT ALL
ALONG.
GARY ABERNATHY, I AM WORRIED FOR
HIS JOB TONIGHT.
HE SAID HOST LIKE TUCKER CARLSON
AND ESPECIALLY SEAN HANNITY HAVE
BEEN SLAMMED FOR SPENDING TWO
YEARS CLAMORING FOR
INVESTIGATION.
IT WOULD BE A SERIOUS JOURNALIST
TO PUT ASIDE THEIR POLITICAL
BIASES AND DELVE INTO THE STORY
THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY BE WORTHY OF
WATERGATE COMPARISONS EVEN IF IT
INCLUDES THE PAINFUL ADMISSION
THAT FOX NEWS HAS BEEN RIGHT ALL
ALONG.
IMAGINE THAT.
TALK SHOW HOSTS RIGHT AGAIN.
WE HAVE LISTED ALL THE TIMES WE
HAVE BEEN RIGHT AND THEY HAVE
BEEN WRONG.
I AM A TALK SHOW HOST, SOMETIMES
REPORT STRAIGHT NEWS, WE    WE'E
REPORT STRAIGHT NEWS, WE    WE'D
REPORT STRAIGHT NEWS, WE    WE'N
REPORT STRAIGHT NEWS, WE    WE'E
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTING LIKE
VETTING OBAMA AND WE HAVE FOR
THE LAST TWO YEARS.
WE ALSO OFFER STRONG OPINIONS, I
DON'T HIDE IT.
SOMETIMES WE TALK ABOUT SPORTS
AND CULTURE AND EVEN LAUGH AND
HAVE FUN.
IF YOU ARE TALK SHOW HOSTS
ELECTED OLD NEWSPAPER.
EVERY NEWS DIVISION IN THIS
COUNTRY WAS WRONG.
I WILL SAY, PEOPLE IN OUR NEWS
DIVISION LIKE
CATHERINE HERRIDGE, ED HENRY, I
WILL NOT NAME EVERYBODY.
WE HAD OUR OWN SOURCES AND BY
THE WAY I WILL PROTECT THEM TO
THE GRAVE.
BY THE WAY I HOPE GARY
ABERNATHY, I HOPE YOU DON'T GET
FIRED.
THE TRUTH ACTUALLY GOT OUT
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
ONLY ONE SMALL PART OF OUR
PROMISE TO HOLD A DEEP STATE
ACCOUNTABLE.
INVESTIGATIONS TAKING PLACE
RIGHT NOW, THE ONLY THING
STANDING IN THE WAY OF THIS
COUNTRY BECOMING A BANANA
REPUBLIC IF WE DON'T INVESTIGATE
INVESTIGATORS AND LOCK UP THE
BAD ACTORS.
THIS COUNTRY WILL BE OVER AS WE
KNOW IT.
ALMOST BE HELD TO ACCOUNT
INCLUDING THOSE WITH HILLARY'S
PROBE, PROSECUTED TRUMP, SPIED
ON A CAMPAIGN, TRY TO RAKE IN
ELECTION AND ATTEMPTED A
DEEP STATE COUP OF THE
UNITED STATES.
IF JUSTICE IS NOT SERVED SAY
GOODBYE TO OUR REPUBLIC AND YOUR
FREEDOMS YOU COULD SAY GOODBYE
TO YOUR PRECIOUS RIGHTS ENDOWED
BY OUR CONSTITUTION.
WE MUST PROTECT ALSO A 99.9%
GOOD PEOPLE IN THE FBI, THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITIES PROTECT
THE INNOCENT PEOPLE HERE AND
AROUND THE GLOBE.